for as long as you can remember legends
have been told about the derelict
mansion upon the hill that casts a
blanket of darkness over the town the
history of the house itself is virtually
unknown and even the town's oldest
residences cannot remember the mansions
origins being an avid history enthusiast
you embark up the mountain to visit the
man hoping to shed some light on the
back story of this crumbling forces of
darkness
[Music]
it's so spooky hello everybody my name
is markiplier and welcome to Spooky's
House of jump-scares I am extremely
tired it's like 4:00 am it's been a long
day of not getting things to work
another arduous task but I'm still here
and I'm gonna play a game that I
intended to play a few days ago I know
that other people have been playing this
performing I'm now totally not copying
them I downloaded this game beforehand I
had the full intention of playing it so
no I'm not a copy nobody up there
copying me but in the future you'll see
what I mean anyway I'm gonna play this
game new game controls dab acid the
mouse to look activate with space got it
I'm so hello I am so tired hello you're
adorable
hi nice I am not humble a thousand is
open ah thanks pretty you're the best
come back I miss you already
alright I don't know if this is the full
game of the demo so I'm just gonna go
for it why not
come on boo keys House of jump-scares
what do you have for me
[Music]
pardon
it's one of the first horror games that
I'm not playing with headphones it's
kind of reminded me of Silent Hill PD at
the moment it's kind of a looping
hallway of nothingness hmm
I don't have headphones so I can't
exactly crank up the volume in my own
head or not that I would be able to do
that anyway huh this is weird
oh hello sprinty sprinty yes yes please
how am I going to get on my knees why is
this room filled with bees I am so tired
I am loopy I'm Luffy cordovan I'm
normally on gold medicine why is this
room purple also I thought this was
boobies house of jumpscares
I hardly noticed a spoopy thing
happening at the moment except that
chair that I don't know if this lulling
me into a false sense of security if
it's still gonna be as adorable as it
was in the beginning spoopy come guide
me spoopy no okay fine I'll just run my
way through hello that important is that
a dildo or a candle I'm gonna go with
the floor latter not the former actually
got a spook I'm here alone whatever the
hell I am I didn't even mention I'm in a
totally different area well this don't
look good that's someone's timeout
corner uh okay I mean I'm in a totally
new place and I'm totally alone no one
else is here at the moment and it's kind
of unnerving knowing that I'm here
totally by myself I mean this is an
actually a scary looking game but I'm
tired it's really late night and I'm a
big baby this is a little cross two
phobic cross two phobic plaster of room
oh hi [ __ ] hell who sits a little
skeleton it scared me what the douche
get out of here that's so adorable Oh
it's cute as hell uh how's having a
discussion with someone recently about
the difference between like visual and
auditory jump-scares because there's
some games that have a lot of like
visual stuff like five nights at
Freddy's is a good example just because
you know it's a whenever you die you get
the jump scare with the things in your
face but there's also other games like
the one that I just played called
dungeon nightmares where it was very
auditory in it like that miss fear guy
he spooked up it to the point where
anything twitched yeah and then the most
of the stuff like the steam was his
auditory so there's two different things
I don't know what I'm trying to say now
but try to discover the hidden meaning
'but i don't know i am very tired how
many rooms aren't gonna go through this
thing hello Stanley parable choice okay
I get the feeling that at some point
soon it's gonna take a turn for the very
worse and then all of a sudden is going
to be nightmare fuel from started Oh
what have you got there oh let me read
that hi my name is jelly and I love gr I
forget oh I heard some oh I'm about to
be moidered
I apologize everybody this looks like
it's gonna be the end of market why is
there someone there's a window why me if
I turn I see if a sir I'm gonna
literally punch a ghost in the dick hey
god damn you pumpkin bastard you dorable
bumpkin bastard you're so cute
oh but I still feel like something's
gonna go horribly wrong oh oh hang in
there oh the guy really did haven't no
they didn't read it at first this place
just seemed cute but I've been here for
days now I'm feeling quite parched now
and I keep getting this feeling like I'm
being watched by something I know the
feeling god damn window
god damn unknown please it's not
romantic at all why would it be romantic
thanks for telling me to hang in there
whoa game saved No
awesome down oh no I'm gonna take the
dirt elevator down into hell oh no I'm
in the turd elevator I didn't know that
okay so what are we doing here huh okay
[Music]
that's from that as Resident Evil very
nice okay so what noose poops await me
here hello you don't have a note and you
didn't know give me a note I need to
know what's going on something bad is
happening something very very slow it's
changed something's changed don't know
what huh
well that's gonna take me forever if the
rooms start going like this also why is
this all in this house
[Music]
uh yeah a bad feeling above this one
ladies and gentlemen oh this is a chair
off by itself over there than I need to
worry about this the way yup I win oh no
note I want to read you go back I know
something is following me but I feel
like I'm prancing through the same rooms
over and over hopefully leaving notes as
breadcrumbs will prove I'm making
progress in reaching something following
me I just hope I don't run out of ink
I'm dreadfully thirsty soon I'll have to
write in my own blood and then drink my
own blood to recycle ink not quite
convincing my first taste is terrible
Shane's are terrible I don't think
drinking it was a very romantic idea I
don't think you know what romantic means
I think you have a flawed under well
that was louder mr. Skellington how
about you go F yourself spoopy oh that
ink woah pratfall spouting splashing
soaking innards in jest invoking nailing
never stops the choking good poem also I
noticed that the font is now red whoa oh
that was a thing that was a real thing
no way uh-uh
nah oh oh oh these are meant to slow me
down huh oh oh we're getting somewhere
now somewhere I don't like how I go once
again getting the room a thousand gonna
be a challenge
ah you buy me uh-huh
okay all right okay just making noises
huh
no no no hello someone following me I'm
looping back to some of the older rooms
that weren't when I went down in the
elevator
Hey Oh did you pop out of you didn't pop
out of nowhere mr. spider-man whoa what
is that whoa what is that is that a
brain in a jar that is a brain in a jar
what is that supposed to be what am I
supposed to ignore this all right then
fine bye yeah I think if I hang around
in a room too long the guy will come
after me oh that ain't good
well I think good at all this first time
I encountered a locked door oh I found
something today is satisfy my unromantic
thirst
I woke from a brief fainted fountain
beef bottle red wine not sure what brand
or year all I gather is that it tastes
strong limit its blood you're drinking
straight blood no wine there it's a good
year it's your year it's your hello mr.
goopy gob it's his ear it's will oh
hello what is this whoa enter what am i
entering excess bin specimen database
docile total fatalities for method art
attack cardboard cutout figure that
Springs out from walls not very
effective all right oh hello active
fatalities 137 physical tearing a mostly
semi-solid based specter that frequently
changes matter States proven very
effective gets weaker slower subjects
well not me then
uh-oh what the hell that is
oh boy should prove useful when release
good god what are you trying to test
here you crazies oh I've never seen her
14th century spirit that was contained
and relocated here tests have yet to
reveal origins but all relevant
information was placed into testing
chamber proved effective but not greatly
more than previous specimens I don't
know that one whoa creature found inside
a church in a small town subjects are
lost over conduct okay now we're getting
to this poo penis it was all just too
secret and cover up air or on subject
seven wait whoa there's one more don't
try to trick me
I know Oh air are all right modify house
layout air roar okay can't do any of
that guess I'll just go fine okay okay
long hallway oh boy
Oh No blue endless oh no oh no oh no oh
no oh no oh no oh no oh no oh no oh no
is it just it better just be really
ridiculously long though though are the
walls getting near the walls are closing
in on me oh my god the walls are oh oh
the walls are closing in on me oh boy
I'm dead I'm dead I'm dead I'm dead I
can't move oh boy
Oh
[Laughter]
game over her their soul wanders an
endless maze good great holy crap those
awesome oh man that went from cute and
adorable the horrifying I bet there's
more oh man I don't have time to play
any more right now but that was really
cool you guys can check the game out for
yourself in the description below
played by God play it there's a ton of
stuff here probably more mystery to
discover I still don't know if it's a
full game or the demo but you'll find
out if you click the link thanks again
everybody so much for watching check out
other scary games that I play down there
or over there and as always I will see
you in the next video bye bye
[Music]